okay i've filled your brain with a bunch
of partial derivatives and size with
respect to x's and y's i think now it's
time to actually
do it with a real differential equation
and make things a little bit more
concrete so let's say i have the
differential
y the differential equation y cosine
of x
plus
x
e to the y
plus
sine
of x
plus already running out of space x
squared
e to the y
minus one
times y prime
is equal to zero well you could probably
already your brain is already hopefully
in the exact differential equations mode
but if you were to see this pattern in
general where you see a function of x
and y here
right this is just some function of x
and y
and then you have another function of x
and y times y prime or times d y d of x
your brain should immediately say if
this isn't separable and i'm not going
to try to make it separable
just because that will take a lot of
time but if it's not separable your
brain said oh maybe this is an exact
equation and you say how is let me let
me test whether this is an exact
equation
so if this is an exact equation this is
our function m which is a function of x
and y
and this is our function n
which is a function of x and y now the
test is to see if the partial of this
with respect to y
is equal to the partial of this with
respect to x
so let's see the
the partial of m with respect to y is
equal to
let's see y is so this cosine of x is
just a constant so it's just cosine of x
cosine of x
plus
now what's the derivative well 2x is
just a constant what's the derivative of
e to the y with respect to y well it's
just e to the y right
so we have the constant on the outside
2x times the derivative with respect to
y such 2x e to the y
fair enough now what is the partial
derivative of this with respect to x
so
n
sub x or the partial of n with respect
to x
so what's the derivative of sine of x
with respect to x well that's easy
that's cosine of x
plus
2x times e to the y right e y is just a
constant because y is constant when
we're taking the partial with respect to
x so plus 2 x
e to the y
and then minus 1 the derivative of a
constant with respect to anything is
going to be 0.
so the derivative of n with the partial
of n with respect to x is cosine of x
plus 2x e to the y which lo and behold
is the same thing as the derivative the
partial of m with respect to
y
so there we have it we've shown that m
of y
is equal to or the partial of m with
respect to y is equal to the partial of
n
with respect to x which tells us
that this is an exact equation
now given that this is an exact equation
given that this is an exact equation oh
yeah my i
my wife stuck up behind me i was
wondering what whether i thought there
was some critter in my house or
something anyway
so we know that this is an exact
equation so what does that tell us well
that tells us that there's some psi
where the partial derivative of psi with
respect to x is equal to m
and the partial derivative of psi with
respect to y is equal to n
and if we know that psi
then we can rewrite our differential
equation as
the derivative
of psi with respect to x is equal to
zero
so
let's solve for zi so we know that the
partial of psi with respect to x is
equal to m so we could write that we
could write
we could write the partial
of psi with respect to x
is equal to
m which is
y
cosine
of x
plus
2 x
e to the y
right that's just here that's my m of x
we could have done it the other way we
could say the partial of y
the partial of z with respect to y is
this thing over here but let's just do
it with x
now to at least get kind of a
a first approximation of what's is not
an approximation but start to get a
sense of it let's take the derivative of
both sides with respect to sorry take
the anti-derivative take the integral of
both sides with respect to x
so if you take the derivative of this
with respect to x if you if you
integrate sorry if you were to take the
antiderivative of this with respect to x
so let's just
so let me just write that down
the partial with respect to x we're
going to take the integrate with respect
to x that is going to be equal to
the integral of this whole thing with
respect to x
cosine of x
plus 2x e to the y
we're integrating with respect to x
and
normally when you integrate with respect
to x you'd say okay plus c right but it
actually could be a plus it could be uh
since this was a partial with respect to
x we could have had some function of y
here in general it couldn't because y we
treat it as a constant right
and that makes sense because if you were
to take the partial of both sides of
this with respect to x if you were to
take the partial of a function that is
only a function of y with respect to x
you would have gotten a zero here so
when you take the antiderivative we're
like oh well there might have been some
function of y here that we lost when we
took the partial with respect to x
so anyway
this will simplify to
psi
right psi is going to be equal to the
integral with respect to x or the
anti-derivative with respect to x here
plus some function of y that we might
have lost when we took the when we took
the partial with respect to x
so let's do that let's figure out this
integral
i'll do it in blue
so y is just a constant so the
anti-derivative of y cosine of x is just
y
sine of x
plus
e to the y is constant so 2x the
anti-derivative 2x with respect to x is
x squared so it's x squared
e
to the y
and then plus
plus some function
some function of y
and if you want to verify this is true
take the partial of this with respect to
x if you take the partial of this with
respect to x you're going to get this in
here which is our function
m up here
and then we take the partial of this
with respect to x you'll get 0 and it'll
get lost okay so we're almost there
we've almost figured out our psi but we
still need to figure out this function
of this function of y
well we know that if we take the partial
of this with respect to y
since this is an exact equation we
should get this we should get our end
function so let's do that
so the partial
i'll switch notation just to expose you
to it the partial of psi with respect to
y is going to be equal to
so here y sine of x sine of x is just a
constant y is just y so the derivative
with respect to y is just sine of x
plus
derivative of e to the y is e to the y x
square is just a constant so it's just x
squared
e to the y
plus what's the partial of f of y with
respect to y which is going to be f
prime
of y
and we also so we what did we do we took
m we integrated with respect to x and we
said well we might have lost some
function of y so we added that to it and
then we took the partial of that that
psi that we've almost constructed and we
took it we took the partial of that with
respect to y
now we know since this is exact that
that is going to equal our n
so our n is up there cosine of x plus
so that's going to be equal to i want to
make sure i can read it up there
to our n
right
oh no sorry n is up here
rn is up here sine of x let me write
that sine of x plus x squared e to the y
minus 1.
so sine of x
sine of x plus x squared e to the y
minus 1
plus x squared e to the y minus 1. that
was just our n from our original
differential equation
and now we can solve for f prime of y so
let's see we get
sine
of x plus x squared e to the y
plus f prime of y
is equal to
sine of x plus x squared e to the y
minus 1.
so let's let's see we can delete sine of
x from both sides
we can delete x squared e to the y from
both sides and then what are we left
with we're left with f prime
of y
is equal to one
and then we're left with
we're left with
f of y
is equal to well it equals y
plus
plus some constant
c
right
so what is our psi now
we wrote our psi up here and we had this
f of y here so we can rewrite it now so
psi is a function of x and y we've
actually pretty much almost done solving
it psi is a function of x and y
is equal to
y
sine
of x
plus
x squared e to the y
y
oh sorry this is f prime of y minus 1 so
this is a minus 1 so this is a minus y
plus c so this is going to be a minus y
plus c so we we solved for psi and so
what does that tell us well we said that
original differential equation up here
using the partial derivative chain rule
that original differential equation
can be rewritten now as the derivative
dx
of psi
is equal to z as a function of x and y
is equal to zero
or if you were to integrate both sides
of this you would get that psi
of x y is equal to
c
is a solution of that differential
equation so if we were to set this as
equal to c that's the differential
equation so we could say y sine of x
plus x squared e to the y minus y now we
could say plus you know this c
plus this c you call that c one is equal
to c two well you can subtract the c's
from both sides and just be left with
the c at the end but anyway we have
solved
this exact equation one first by
recognizing it was exact by taking the
partial of this with respect to y and
say seeing if that was equal to the
partial of n with respect to x
once we saw that they were equal we're
like okay this is going to be exact so
let's figure out psi
since this is exact
m is going to be the partial of psi with
respect to x
n is the partial of psi with respect to
y then to figure out y we integrated m
with respect to x
and we got
this
but since we said oh well you know
instead of a plus c it could have been a
function of y there because we took the
partial with respect to x and this might
have been lost to figure out the
function of y we then took ours
our psi that we figured out took the
partial of that with respect to y
got this and we said this was an exact
equation so this is going to equal our n
of x our n of x y
we set those equal to each other and
then we solved for
f of y
and then we had our final psi
our final psi was this and then the
differential equation because of the
chain rule of partial derivatives we
could rewrite the differential equation
as this the solution is this and so this
is the solution to our differential
equation
see you in the next video